mr. speak madam Speaker I now yield one
minute to the distinguished speaker of
the house gentlelady
distinguished speakers recognized for
one minute thank you madam Speaker I
thank the gentleman for yielding for his
tremendous leadership in helping us
honor the Constitution of the United
States I also extend my gratitude to
congressman Schiff who will be presiding
later in the day my colleagues this
morning and every morning when we come
together members rise and pledge
allegiance to the flag every day all
across America children in school
members of the military officials and
those civically engaged also pledge
allegiance to the flag let us recall
what that pledge says I pledge
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
the Republic for which it stands is what
we are here to talk about today a
republic if we can keep it we gathered
today under the dome of this temple of
democracy to exercise one of the most
solemn powers that this body can take
the impeachment of the President of the
United States no member regardless of
party or politics comes to Congress to
impeach a president but every one of us
as our first act as a member of Congress
stood on this historic House floor
before our beautiful American flag and
raised our hands in this sacred oath I
do solemnly swear that I will support
and defend the Constitution of the
United States against all enemies
foreign and domestic so help me God
for 230 years members have taken that
sacred oath which makes us custodians of
the Constitution when our founders
declared independence
established a new nation they crafted a
system of government unlike everyone
ever seen before a republic starting
with the sacred words we the people for
centuries Americans have fought and died
to defend democracy for the people but
very sadly now our founders vision of a
republic is under threat from actions
from the White House that is why today
as Speaker of the House I solemnly and
sadly opened the debate on the
impeachment of the President of the
United States if we do not act now we
would be derelict in our duty it is
you
stablish fact that the president
violated the Constitution it is a matter
of fact that the president is an ongoing
threat to our national security and the
integrity of our elections the basis of
our democracy
hundreds of historians legal scholars
and formal prosecutors regardless of
party have stated that the president
committed impeachable offenses since
today is a national civics lesson though
a sad one I submit these documents for
the record and commend them for students
to study that objection so order thank
you madam Speaker what we are discussing
today is the stablish fact that the
president again violated the
Constitution is a matter of fact that
the president is again an ongoing threat
to our national security and the
testimony of decorated war heroes
distinguished diplomats and patriotic
career public servants some of the
president's own appointees over the past
weeks have told us this the president
used the power of his public office to
obtain an improper personal political
benefit at the expense of America's
national security when the president
weakens a democratic ally that is
advancing American security interests by
fighting an American adversary the
president weakens America this abuse of
power
also jeopardizes the integrity of our
elections all Americans agree that
American voters should choose our
president not some foreign government
the founders understood that it is
profoundly corrosive for our democracy
for a president to invite interference
in our elections as George Washington
our nation's patriot under whose gaze we
stand today warned history and
experience prove that foreign influence
is one of the most painful foes of
republican government George Washington
sadly the American people have witnessed
further wrongs of the president which
necessitate the
second article of impeachment
obstruction of Congress when the
president's wrongdoing was revealed he
launched an unprecedented indiscriminate
and categorical campaign of defiance and
obstruction never before in the history
of our nation have we seen a president
declare an active-active
he is above the law the president goes
even so far as to say and act on this
absurdity when he says article 2 says I
can do whatever I want no it doesn't
that recklessness is a profound
violation of the Constitution and our
republic which endure because of our
system of separation of power three
co-equal branches each a check and
balance on the other a republic again if
we can keep it the founders great fear
of a rogue or corrupt president is the
very reason why they enshrined
impeachment in the Constitution as one
founder William Davy of North Carolina
warned unless the Constitution contained
an impeachment provision a president
might spare no efforts or means whatever
to get himself re-elected another
founder George Mason insisted that the
president who procured his appointment
in the first instance through improper
and corrupt acts might repeat his guilt
and return to power we in Congress
article one the legislative branch must
stand up and make clear to the American
people and to all people that this body
still stands by the principles enshrined
in the Constitution and defended by
generations of Americans last week and
observance of the 75th anniversary of
the Battle of the Bulge members travel
to that hallowed ground to express our
gratitude to the heroes of freedom who
sacrificed everything to secure victory
of freedom over tyranny not just for
America but for the world the veterans
of that battle who were there in their
90's told us how after the war was won
the Europeans to
they whom they liberated would ask why
did you risk us you don't know us and
give your lives to save us
we're not Americans and our men would
say we came here to fight for you not
because you are Americans because we are
Americans as our beloved chairman Elijah
Cummings an oversight committee chair
our North Star said when announcing his
support for this action quote when the
history books are written about this
tumultuous error I want them to show
that I was among those in the House of
Representatives who stood up to
lawlessness and tyranny he also said
almost prophetically when we are dancing
with the angels the question will be
what we did we do to make sure we kept
our democracy intact Elijah as you know
has since passed on now he is dancing
with the angels and I know that he and
all of us here are very proud the moral
courage of members once you honor the
vision of our founders for a republic
the sacrifice of our men and women in
uniform to defend it and the aspirations
of our children to live freely within it
today we are here to defend democracy
for the people may god bless america
I yield back the balance of my time the
lady is back